- So have y'all ever met?
Have you met Michael?
- Oh yeah, Michael and- We were teammates.
- Yeah, we were teammates
on a game show and we won.
- [Nikki] We won.
- We won.
- [Nikki] Oh, don't rub it in.
- Was it because of Michael's coaching?
- Yeah, I mean, Michael, his
coaching was just top notch.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love it.
Oh, I love "Hollywood Game
Night". I've done that-
(indistinct chattering)
I've done that a couple
times, it's so fun.
- So fun.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- Oh my goodness!
- So I have to say your sister's right and
you work in the industry,
but all sisters fight.
Okay. Let's just get this out.
What's you're worst, like
your best, worst fight.
- Oh, I mean, there's been a
lot, but there's been a lot.
There's one that I really
always liked to talk about.
- Oh gosh.
- It was a proud moment in seventh grade
even though I got trouble.
- Oh my God. We were in junior high, Okay.
- We did.
And it was great because when you walked
do you remember the
desk that like, kind of
you just only could get in one way.
- Yeah they had the
hole thing on the side.
- Yeah. So we got in and you did something
you said something to
me that I didn't like.
And then, so we got into her desk.
- [Kelly] It was your
fault is what she's saying.
- It was.
- My backpack's cuter
than yours, I don't know.
- So I kicked her desk over, knowing that
if it fell on the one side-
- [Kelly] She'd be trapped!
- -her legs would wiggle
and she couldn't get out.
- She did that.
- That is wrong! Funny (laughs)
- [Brie] In a way Funny but wrong.
- Wrong, wrong it was so wrong.
- My teacher didn't like it.
So she was like, "Brie, come here!"
And I'm like, "What?"
And so I got into the principal's office.
- And that was the last time we ever were
in a class together throughout school.
- [Kelly] Oh, they separated you.
- Ever ever again
- Separated us yeah.
Well, job well done you
got your independence.
That's amazing.
Okay. Brie, I have to ask you about this
cause from this moment, from your show
The Real Dirty Dancing,
well, let's watch first.
♪ I wanna show you what love's all about ♪
♪ Darling tonight ♪
♪ Now I've got you in my sight ♪
- Get it! You've gotta get it! Here's my-
- Wowee!
- [Kelly] Just watching
Michael's face! Wait, wait.
So how does, do you
tell your husband like,
"Hey well there's this show I'm doing",
do you watch it with him?
Like how does this play out?
Because I've been married.
- [Nikki] Yeah.
- I don't know it that
would have gone over well.
- Well I think I do lie
to him when it airs.
I'm like, "Did you catch it last night?"
And he's like, "Wasn't on".
I'm like, "Oh yeah, it's tonight, oops."
But I, you know, he's actually great.
And I think it's cause
he's in entertainment.
He's also a professional
wrestler and gets it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So he's really supportive.
He definitely has hard times.
Like I think Antonio Gates
is gonna get a 'yes lock' or
choke hold put on him.
- I love it though. He's
secure. So he is- He's fine.
- [Brie] Yeah. He's really good.
- You are such a great dancer.
- Well it was hard.
It was hard to bring up that
'dirty' side cause like-
- [Kelly] Really?
- You know,
- Or I mean yeah, me too.
- Yeah Kelly!
- You know, and it was the eye contact.
Like when you're moving your hips
with someone and they're like,
"okay, you have to make sure"
- [Kelly] I love that!
- I love it too.
- Definitely!
- See that was like the
uncomfortable part for me.
- Oh my God I think I go
into like, I go into like,
even like when you went clubbing you know
when you were younger, you
didn't like just look for fun,
like you'd just go into character.
- [Brie] Yeah, I would
but I was single then.
- Or role play?
- Like I would do it
then, I think it was more
because I married and I don't know if it's
being a mom for so long, you
give your body to your kids.
So then all of a sudden I'm gonna have to
give it to a stranger.
Someone I don't know.
And that was like the part I had to like,
the wall had to break down.
- [Kelly] I can see that.
Right?
- Yeah. I don't know if it's weird that
I wouldn't have a problem with that.
- [Brie] Oh my gosh see look-
- You were doing just fine there
- [Kelly] It's so great,
I love that though.
Dancing is so fun.
My friends will make
fun of me on group text
cause they're like, "what
are you gonna do now?"
I'm like, I'm gonna go home
and dance, just by myself.
- [Brie] Yeah.
- Just put some music,
just having a good time.
Well now you can call me I'll come over.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- Dirty dance with you.
- I will stare directly in your eyes.
I'm kidding, I'm just kidding.
So wait, you've got a new show as well.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] America's Got Talent Extreme.
So you're working with Simon
Cowell who I know well.
- [Nikki] Yes.
- [Kelly] Yes. Is it fun working
with him or is it intense?
- Amazing.
- [Kelly] He's so nice.
- So nice, I was totally
intimidated the first day
to come in and meet him like,
here I'm gonna be a
judge with Simon Cowell.
My first time ever was super intimidating.
And then he was so chill and
cool and like motivating.
And I was like, this is amazing.
And then we all just clicked
and it was so much fun the whole time.
- He's actually very supportive.
He's just, very honest as well.
- Yeah which kind of makes
you kind of laugh out loud.
Like his honesty, I would
laugh and I'd be like
"I was thinking that, but
I wasn't gonna say it"
- Exactly. That's his whole thing.
- Yeah, totally.
- Oh my gosh well I love your shows.
I love you guys so much.
Your energy is so great too.
So you can see The Real Dirty Dancing,
that's Tuesdays on Fox and
America's Got Talent Extreme
premieres tonight on NBC.